my name it burn ha and welcome to
episode I don't have a [ __ ] Bell
anyway we have a lot of packages and
stuff I have too apparently and there's
a lot somewhere here alright let's start
with a big one for his elders show this
one I want that what it could be don't
do that I'm sorry all right finally this
bitch's elfin now listen what she tied
yes I am Pro this [ __ ] it's from I've
bet Finn from adventure time
we have a happy dear patty pie I hope
that you received this package before
Christmas
good job Jessie I hope you enjoy the
presents and a Merry Christmas
Thank You Brad Thank You candies oh okay
I don't know why but someone send me
body lotion so raspberry flavor which is
really good too
for your skin I guess maybe someone
thinks I have bad skin then they want to
send me body lotion so I guess I get
stones and body lotions really I pray I
appreciate that I can really appreciate
the body lotion bro thank you thank you
thank thank you for the brown body
lotion I love body lotion whoa
this one is my face red okay my name is
Jose and it's probably Josie or
something that's question I just wanted
to thank you for the various even not
bad days he make me laugh that's really
nice my wife Lauren and I live in
California we noticed in one of your
ears that you like Swedish candies so we
decided to send you some mexic a lesson
keeping awesome breath that's awesome
thank you thank you we have like a lot
it's so much candy holy [ __ ] there's a
lot of [ __ ] Ganic anything dump
triple this [ __ ] these things Lucas
man God good I have
I have to try a little ass manga I am
amazed by this seriously
well no I got the little custom Mike
am I supposed to sniff this one of us
it's weird
really weird Wow Mexican candy I have
wow that's a pretty green [ __ ]
Catholic no I'm just gonna [ __ ] tear
this whoa 235 from medicine Lauren we
got a really nice fat heart hope you can
say it I like it
it's a I'm going out with piggies yeah
it's painted with like crayon alright
what hides underneath yeah
first of all we got piggy yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm sexy I'm sexy and I know wait
what oh there's a cheese on my head
you're ridiculous
I will use this when me and my stay have
a break up I'm gonna put on this hat and
just go out and get ladies you know I
don't see how any lady can deny anyone
with a hat cheese on their head I'm
cheesy I know you're famous no no I'm
not so you don't have time to go through
all I'd try my best at least my friend
Lauren I discovered you about three
months ago and we're excited to call
ourself a newly established three months
is a long time for me at least I don't
know I appreciate that you bros stay
around for a long time it makes me happy
that you get to do what you do love for
a living and as an aspiring writer I
sometimes am doubtful that I ever be
able to get where I am what I want to be
in life but watching you play have fun
and generally enjoy what you do makes me
think twice anymore dismayed to me to
strive towards the goal I set for myself
you know I I really really appreciate
this message because some remain not
know I used to study for years in
university I got I got a little really
lucky to get into that universe today
was a really good University your
futures in good hands pretty much that
type of deal and I just really felt like
after a while I was really proud that I
got in and I because I worked really
hard for it and I started really hard
but it wasn't what I wanted to do with
life I realized that after a couple of
years I yeah I I don't wanna work
somewhere where I just do something that
I don't like and it just it was really
the low point in my life where I really
felt like things were pointless and
that's why I started out of boredom like
I was bored with studying and I started
YouTube video and it's crazy how much it
changed my life and I feel I feel really
really happy
I thought I could inspire other people
and I inspire you bros to do do what you
love to do and I I really really think
if you if you do what you love to do
then you really put your heart and soul
into it then I think you will succeed in
what you do so that's my best self today
haha sorry that was a little too serious
no but hey alright more hats you know I
should just [ __ ] change the name to
this to this Chotu pewdiepie tries out
new hats oh yeah there were more hats I
actually like these ones these are
really nice these are sent by a company
called and life high consciousness not
bad not bad
thanks for the free clothes I really
appreciate it it's a little big I think
alright like I really think I look
stupid in hats
but hey 25 try science a straw
a straw this is the package it came with
oh I almost missed the douchebag glasses
look at this I want a cool glass of
something cool oh just kidding I am cool
and you know it
alright I just wanted to give you a
birthday card as classy as sophisticated
as you are oh yeah it's it's Felix the
human and my other dog I lost a zebra's
no I love adventure time that's kind of
cool and it says happy birthday kids a
monkey is telling me happy birthday
which means I will this is really late
isn't it my birthday was in October
oh well thanks bro I really appreciate
that alright press that's all the time I
had for today thank you so much for all
all the mail and crazy stuff excuse me
seriously I have some bad news
unfortunately during Christmas I will be
going away for two weeks
wellhe brothers who live without you may
I I think you bros are fine I have
uploaded so many videos and I think
there should always be something to
watch if you really miss me I'm gonna go
to back to Sweden spend some time with
friends and then me and my family and
might are going to Florida for whatever
you do it's good to take a break every
once in awhile it's not really that good
I feel like this week I have literally
just put like 12 hours into making
videos and then go to sleep and then
follow or to making videos and then go
to sleep and even even kids need to
break every once in a while so hopefully
I will return with the tan on my face
and tear to my eye because I miss your
breath anyway thank you bros for making
these years together the best years of
my life you bros do so much for me and i
tell you enough how much I appreciate it
I will miss you a lot when I go go but
it will make coming back even more sweet
day so stay awesome and I'll see you in
a while